for those watching television news in
russia there is no war in ukraine only a
special military operation designed to
root out nazis and it's all going
according to plan
[Music]
we destroyed the whole city mass chaos
was created and we can safely report it
is now liberated wait we bombed it and
raised it destroyed it entirely killed
every person that we saw correct until
they were free all thanks to
putin
[Music]
the stanley cup playoffs are back in
full force and this year's mvp vlad
putin of course watch as he skillfully
weaves through their expert defense and
coming up who uncovered artifacts of
priceless expense let me guess
[Music]
we destroyed their infantry meaning we
killed some infants oh my god we lost
several tanks uh we wrote off some
equipment this reminds me of a story i
was out eating greek and they brought
out that flaming thing ah liberating the
cheese no it's you're not getting the
point it's as if this is all planned how
can you look at what's happening and say
ah never mind i understand
putin
putin not good
putin really not good
hey where are you taking me
this is not chamomile
hey